bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
d'une émission sur le poids des
influenceurs ce soir avec notre grand
témoin la féministe Louise obery bonsoir
bonsoir alias my better self sur les
réseaux vous avez 25 ans 700000
followers et un message que vous répétez
en permanence soyez vous-même
libérez-vous des injonctions assumez
vous sans phare on va en parler toutes
les deux tout à l'heure mais on va
commencer avec la phase plus sombre des
réseaux les dérives des influenceurs
certains les appellent les influx
voleurs placement de produits machine à
cash dropshipping jusqu'où peut-on
monnayer son influence sur les réseaux
sociaux les députés s'emparent du sujet
à l'Assemblée c'est notre grand débat
avec nos invités dans un instant avant
de retrouver à 20h15 nos affranchis et
leur parti pris et puis Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée Aubery
vous êtes prêts je suis prête ça vous
regarde on y va
[Musique]
qui aurait pu imaginer qu'ils allaient
générer un six gros business on va
débattre des influenceurs se soient et
comme toujours et bien il y a du bon et
il y a du mauvais et députés ont décidé
de faire tous ensemble le ménage de
poser des règles cadres juridique et
pour une fois et bien ils sont tous
d'accord pour le faire bonsoir Arthur de
Laporte et merci d'être là vous êtes
députés socialistes du Calvados et vous
êtes le co-auteur d'une proposition de
loi adoptée cette semaine à l'unanimité
à l'Assemblée nationale proposition pour
réguler ce métier d'influenceurs dont
vous êtes également à l'initiative une
fois n'est pas le coutume Stéphane
vogeta vous êtes député renaissance de
des Français qui habitent en Espagne et
au Portugal et puis vous avez fait
conférence de presse commune on vous a
mis à côté majorité et opposition voilà
c'est assez rare pour être souligné
bonsoir Magali Berdah bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes souvent présenté
comme la patronne la Papesse on répète
partout cette expression la Papesse les
influenceurs vous dirigez l'agence
Shauna events qui fait beaucoup beaucoup
les d'encre 40 millions de chiffre
d'affaires ça c'était 2020 un
portefeuille d'une centaine
d'influenceurs principalement venue d'un
télé-réalité et vous faites l'objet d'un
cyber-harcèlement d'une violence inouïe
cyber-harcèlement massif initié par le
rappeur Booba on va en parler tout à
l'heure bonsoir aurélieue merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes expert des réseaux
sociaux directrice influence et
communication de cision France voilà
pour la présentation Louise obery
évidemment votre regard nous intéresse
sur ce débat n'hésitez pas à intervenir
on va commencer par le biais de Stéphane
blackovski comme chaque soir on connaît
évidemment Nabilla et ses placements de
produits mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres influenceurs dérives de sang en
seconde pour nous raconter tout cela
c'est le chrono de la côte tout de suite
et on se retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir
à toutes bonsoir à tous quel regard vous
portez alors sur ce monde là faut bien
reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui la télévision
c'est plutôt un truc de vieux je sais
pas si vous savez mais l'âge moyen du
public de Arte France 5 c'est un peu
notre cible 63 ans donc il y a pas de
raison que notre public soit beaucoup
plus jeune en revanche des jeunes pas du
tout eux quand ils s'informent ils ont
d'autres manières regardez les sondages
nous en parle il s'informent très
majoritairement sur les réseaux sociaux
sur Internet il y en a à peine un quart
qui regarde des JT à la télé quand on
fait de lire la presse n'en parlons pas
on voit bien que c'est pas tout à fait
leur truc alors forcément ça change un
petit peu ce qu'ils ont en tête
puisqu'il s'informent de nous donc on
arrive à des moments où voilà ce les
croyances assez répandues finalement
chez les moins de 25 ans un tiers pense
que les vaccins sont toxiques ou que le
réchauffement climatique n'est pas dû à
l'activité humaine et puis de faire
sourire on a quand même un petit 20%
pour les pyramides construits par des
extraterrestres et quand à l'idée que la
terre est plate il y en a 15% qui trouve
que oui pourquoi pas c'est une hypothèse
qu'on peut envisager alors nous sur LCP
en tant qu'amoureux de la connaissance
bon on est un petit peu concernés
maintenant il y a une autre manière de
voir les choses mettons vous soyez homme
d'affaires ou femme d'affaires
d'ailleurs le fait que les jeunes soient
prêts à croire n'importe quoi mais c'est
une opportunité parce que vous allez
voir leur vendre n'importe quoi mais
évidemment alors on va prendre un
exemple peut-être que vous connaissez
Nabilla je dis ça pour notre public si
vous vous souvenez bah si souvenez-vous
bref toujours est-il que elle en 2018
elle nous donnait des conseils pour
investir dans la crypto-monnaie de
Bitcoin on écoute même si vous y
connaissez rien ça vous permet de gagner
de l'argent sans investir beaucoup genre
vous investissez des petites sommes
genre moi j'ai dû mettre à peu près 1000
euros j'ai déjà gagné 800 euros c'est
vraiment sûr c'est vraiment cool et si
ça vous a si ça vous intéresse vraiment
vous pouvez y aller les yeux fermés les
yeux fermés c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
fait Elon Musk qui regardait il n'a pas
du tout à le regretter puisqu'il a juste
perdu 140 millions dans l'affaire bon
pour Nabilla elle elle a quand même été
condamnée à 20000 euros pour publicité
mensongère mais on va pas résumer les
influenceurs à ces quelques dérives
c'est aussi un secteur qui joue un vrai
rôle important aujourd'hui dans
l'économie on va prendre une poubelle
histoire une marque qui s'appelle
Jennifer qui était des vêtements bon
marché qui était un peu en perte de
visite en train de devenir ringarde une
nouvelle équipe s'est installé ils sont
dit si on veut parler aux jeunes ça
passe par les influenceurs et ils ont
notamment choisi cette jeune femme qui
s'appelle Léna situation comme égérie et
ça a fait redémarrer la marque donc je
saigne d'un grand lecteur parmi néo
spectateurs donc référence littéraire
quand elle a publié son livre à Lena
situation bah au classement elle était
devant Marc Levy devant Guillaume Musso
donc vous voyez effectivement que il y a
une très grosse influence maintenant on
en a parlé aussi ce qui fait que le
débat d'un seul coup arrive à une des
journées c'est qu'il y a une grosse
polémique lancée par quelqu'un que vous
connaissez sans doute quelqu'un qui est
du 9-2 un mauvais garçon on va voir
l'image s'appelle Booba donc au cas où
tout le monde ne connaît pas Booba c'est
un peu le génie du rap non je dis ça
c'est un gars qui remplit le stade de en
France et donc quand il dit un truc
forcément c'est un très gros impact sur
la jeunesse et sur le public et donc il
s'est engagé dans une polémique avec
Magali Berda en accusant de soutenir des
influenceurs assez peu scrupuleux
imagine qu'on va en parler juste avant
le débat il y a une phrase que je ne
veux pas entendre dans ce débat c'est de
dire oui mais vous savez la majorité des
influenceurs sont déjà honnêtes non non
la majorité des influenceurs ne sont pas
honnêtes je vous dis pourquoi parce que
la direction générale des fraudes a mené
une enquête cette année et que voilà 60%
des influenceurs qui ont été visés par
cette enquête étaient en anomalie
notamment sur le respect des règles pour
la publicité vis-à-vis des jeunes donc
je comprends que Bruno Le Maire notre
shérif décide de mettre un petit peu
d'ordre dans ce Far West et si vous
pouvez l'aider tant mieux les députés
l'aideront sans doute merci beaucoup
pour ce billet piquant mordant comme
chaque soir je vous propose une chose on
va il y a beaucoup de sujets on va venir
sur les dérives mais je voudrais quand
même parler de ce qui vous arrive est-ce
que c'est toujours le cauchemar
aujourd'hui vous êtes toujours soumise à
ce cyber-harcèlement initié par Booba
ça ne s'est pas calmer non donc il faut
expliquer peut-être ce qui s'est passé
le rapport Booba cibler directement et
envoyer toute sa
toute autre chose que les placements de
produits ça a duré pendant un mois et
demi sur mon physique sur ma famille sur
ma religion sur mes voilà sur ma fille
et j'ai déposé une plainte une enquête a
été ouverte il y a eu des arrestations
il y a eu 23 arrestations en tout dans
tout ce dossier pour l'instant l'enquête
est encore en cours et donc ça a placé
ce dossier dans un cadre de
cyber-harcèlement c'est violent et vous
avez du même déménager je crois vos
bureaux votre bébé on a humilié tous les
jours et
en fait un mois et demi après quand il a
su qu'il y avait une enquête ouverte
contre lui pour cyber-harcèlement
aggraver
et bien il a cherché des failles et les
failles c'était de parler de la
téléréalité ça a pas vraiment pris après
c'était parler d'autre chose puis après
parler d'emplacement de produit et quand
il a vu que ça a pris puisque c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu des dérives c'est une
vérité et bien il s'est enfoncé
là-dedans en faisant un appel à
témoignage mais sans demander de
précision c'est à dire qu'il a dit si
vous avez été victime d'un fumer en
soeur d'un flux voleur
écrivez-moi mais sans que les gens
précises est-ce que ça dépend de Magali
Burda ou pas donc voilà alors je parce
que c'est pas le sujet de notre débat
mais je voudrais vraiment voilà c'était
des
plantes c'est vraiment des injures et
même des menaces de morts voilà des
appels au viol enfin c'est vraiment
totalement inacceptable sur ce point là
il y a pas de discussion vous condamnez
on a eu l'occasion d'en parler mercredi
dernier dans la commission des affaires
économiques où il y a un collègue qui
nous a dit bon qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette affaire nous on
est absolument clair déjà la première
chose c'est que personne personne ne
mérite ne doit être cyber-harcelé
aujourd'hui
Magali Berda mais aussi beaucoup
d'influenceurs et surtout
d'influenceuses font l'objet de
cyber-harcèlement ça n'est pas
acceptable mais ça on le condamne
évidemment pour ce que vous subissez ce
que vous vivez mais on le condamne aussi
dans l'absolu et de manière générale
voilà ce que nous souhaitons dire je
pense que Stéphane j'ajouterais
volontiers qu'effectivement et moi même
d'ailleurs j'ai mentionné à quelques
reprises le nom de Booba au cours de
cette instruction on va dire de ce
processus législatif et je le reconnais
et je l'assume mais j'ai mentionné dans
Booba effectivement comme celui d'un
lanceur d'alerte c'est un des nombreux
lanceurs d'alerte qui m'ont alerté sur
le sujet qui m'ont incité à me pencher
sur le sujet à écouter des victimes et
d'ailleurs je dois dire que certaines de
ces victimes ont représentants de
victimes sont venus dans le bureau et
m'ont demandé à ce que leur nom ne soit
pas révélé parce que c'est même victime
son sujet à des pressions à des
pressions extérieures à des menaces de
violence et je crois qu'effectivement il
faut faire l'ancien appel collectif
est-ce que tout le monde pendant ce
processus on fasse tous faire un effort
pour travailler d'une manière sereine
pour essayer de mettre des règles du jeu
sur ce sujet tout le monde essaye de
calmer les esprits et surtout d'arrêter
de mettre fin aux intimidations et aux
violences sur un sujet précis mais de là
voilà à ce que des bureau privé se
retrouve sur les réseaux il y a une
nuance ceci étant posé Magali Bernard on
voudrait comprendre comment fonctionne
votre business puisque vous êtes une
pionnière est-ce que vous pouvez
expliquer comment fonctionne votre
agence vous mettez en relation des
marques avec des influenceurs c'est très
simple on reçoit des demandes de
partenariat on les traite on valide des
sites on les regarde on les examine on
regarde si l'objet du site déjà illégal
ensuite on regarde comment est fait le
site et une fois que c'est validé on le
propose à l'influenceur l'influenceur
reçoit donc une demande de partenariat
il regarde pareil le site il peut
demander d'abord de recevoir le produit
et il nous dit OUI ou NON donc il valide
lui-même son son placement de produit
c'est à dire qu'on a aucune obligation
en fait on ne peut pas obliger en
influenceur à faire un poste qu'il ne
veut pas
si il y a un tarif ou comment vous
décidez les prix à payer pour une vidéo
en fonction de l'influenceur en fonction
d'influenceur c'est très varié
aujourd'hui le nombre de followers ne
veut absolument plus rien dire non je
compare c'est en taux d'engagement c'est
à dire vraiment la qualité de
l'influenceur
vous avez des influenceurs qui ont
100.000 200000 abonnés qui seront
peut-être des fois plus vendeurs que
certains qui ont un million ça ne veut
plus rien dire aujourd'hui il y a plus
de règles à ce niveau là donc le prix se
fait en fonction de la de la valeur de
l'influenceur et et c'est aussi grâce à
1000 euros pour la vidéo éphémère de 24
heures de Nabilla c'est le maximum ça
c'est sorti ce chiffre pour une vidéo
j'ai pas vu où est sorti cette vidéo
désolé non mais ça peut aller en savoir
des ordres de grandeur
avec moi donc je peux pas dévoiler ses
tarifs mais mais c'est ça peut aller oui
à plusieurs milliers d'euros comme ça
peut être quelques centaines d'euros
tout dépend mais ça reste très
accessible par rapport à une promotion
par exemple à la télévision parce
qu'aujourd'hui une pub à la télé quand
vous avez vous voulez toucher un million
et demi de personnes vous payez 50 ou 70
000 euros ce qui n'est pas accessible
aux petites entreprises qui souhaitent
se développer alors je rappelle que vous
travaillez principalement avec des
influenceurs venus de la télé-réalité
non un peu l'étiquette qu'on m'a donné
que j'ai voulu prendre aussi attention
que j'ai accepté mais j'ai plusieurs
déjà on a plusieurs structures on nation
et puis après on a plusieurs filiale qui
ne représente pas forcément des
candidats télé-réalité on a un peu de
tout sauf que c'est vrai que je suis
très proche de mes candidatéralités et
c'est vrai qu'on a créé des liens et que
et puis j'ai été animatrice d'une
émission télé-réalité et après il faut
expliquer voilà ça a été racheté vous
dirigez sur Niven mais qui maintenant
fait partie du groupe j'ai vendu Shane
Evans en 2018
100% des parts je suis resté directrice
commerciale et j'ai racheté shonaven
c'est à moi donc et donc j'ai toujours
non c'est fini c'est fini je leur ai
racheté leur parties un peu de
l'écosystème qui fait qu'au fond faut
expliquer ça aux gens banijess et la
télé-réalité les Anges de la réalité
c'est les Marseillais pardon les
Marseillais et c'est Hanouna aussi TPMP
c'est beaucoup de production comme il y
a aussi Nagui à l'excella roche-joubert
qui a une forme d'écosystème qui s'auto
entretien entre les stars de la
téléréalité qui ensuite deviennent
influenceurs c'est à dire que nous enfin
je quand j'étais banniji c'était
vraiment chaque pro était complètement
indépendante de chacune et c'est
vraiment leur valeur et voilà bon
Aurélie Siou pour bien comprendre c'est
un secteur en plein boom est-ce que
quand on est influenceur au sens large
on monnaie forcément son influence ou
pas du tout en fait il faut savoir que
le marché de l'influence est un marché
qui est protéiforme
et il faut distinguer deux influences
pour commencer l'influence qui est
effectivement monétisée qu'on peut
appeler influence commerciale mercantile
qui est un business effectivement et de
l'autre côté et qui représente 1% du
marché de l'influence et ensuite les 99%
restants qui est une influence qui est
organique
naturelle
les temporalités sont très différentes
la temporalité est beaucoup plus longue
sur l'influence organique par exemple
des exemples d'influence
très très grosses influenceurs qui ne
serait pas dans alors non mercantile
dans sans placement de produit il y en a
il y en a il y en a énormément parce que
il y a énormément de de typologie
d'influenceurs mais en termes de Hugo
Clément on peut parler du GO du
godetrips voilà on peut aussi parler de
chef d'entreprise Hugo décrypte fait des
collaborations mais je pense que en
effet c'est pas le même type de
collaboration et c'est d'ailleurs ce que
je trouve on n'entend pas assez sur les
plateaux c'est que c'est très bien de
mettre l'accent sur les dérives qui
existent dans l'influence mais du coup
je pense que pour pas mal de personnes
qui maîtrisent pas forcément tous les
tenants les aboutissants de ce secteur
ça donne l'impression que influence
égale aujourd'hui escroquerie non
escroquerie en fait argent c'est pas le
problème c'est le cas des plateaux télé
c'est le cas des médias c'est le cas de
à peu près tous les entreprises qui
cherchent à développer leur entreprise
et ça c'est en soi on peut pas leur
reprocher mais par contre ce côté
escroquerie je pense que c'est
aujourd'hui
enfin on met l'accent uniquement là
dessus sans préciser que Hugo par
exemple son but c'est d'informer les
gens
Camille Étienne qui est une activiste
qui a quand même permis l'interdiction
d'exploitation des fonds marins elle l'a
fait grâce à l'influence
vous pouvez avoir beaucoup d'influences
c'est encore une fois c'est pas un
problème de vouloir gagner de l'argent
non bien sûr c'est parce que le fait le
problème c'est d'escroquer tout le monde
ne fait pas forcément son influence un
métier ça peut être une cause aussi
Arthur de la porte moi je voudrais
savoir c'est le Far West aujourd'hui ce
métier il y a pas de règle il y a très
peu de réglementation c'est beaucoup
d'auto régulation c'est à dire qu'il y a
des règles qui sont fixées par notamment
de l'Autorité de régulation de la
publicité mais elles sont pas forcément
partagées partout et elles sont pas
forcément contraignantes alors exemple
quand vous faites de la publicité vous
êtes influenceurs sur votre page
instinct vous n'êtes pas obligé de dire
c'est de la publicité vous êtes obligé
aujourd'hui du métier normalement et
dans les règles générales on est censé
dire que c'est de la publicité mais
comment on le dit normalement ça doit
être dans les hashtags par exemple ça
doit être on est censé le mettre dans le
hashtag sponsorisé en début de
maintenant alors là c'est ça a été enfin
on nous a signalé ça il y a pas il y a
très peu de temps nous on mettait le
hashtag sponsorisé au moment de mettre
le code promo par exemple il faut le
mettre au début et c'est comme les
photos Instagram il faut le mettre en
début de texte et pas la fin il faut pas
mettre hashtag add parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'influenceurs qui mettent
hashtag parce que ça fait plus discret
sauf que c'est pas français les Français
ne comprennent pas ce que c'est hashtag
a donc il faut rester dans le hacking ça
c'est le règlement la réglementation
européenne c'est ça c'est de la
réglementation interne liée à la RPP le
temps de la DGCCRF quand ils le mettent
pas et ça en fait on peut s'appuyer
dessus mais c'est un règlement qui
évolue mais qui n'est pas de nature
législative et enfin nous ce qu'on veut
c'est aller plus loin parce que comme
vous le disiez il faut recréer il y a
c'est pas naturel législative parce que
ce n'est pas la loi qui l'a détermine le
consommateur d'une promotion comme quoi
elle est rémunérée c'est obligatoire ce
que je dis c'est que le niveau
est-ce que c'est sponsorisé est-ce que
c'est dans le premier ou le troisième
hashtag ça c'est pas la loi qui le dit
par contre nous ce qu'on veut c'est
faire en sorte et notamment dans la
provision on doit que nous avons déposé
et qui est amené à devenir la règle
c'est redonner de la confiance parce que
finalement on dit pas que faire de
l'argent c'est mal c'est juste faire de
l'argent de manière malhonnête ou en
abusant des gens là c'est pas bien c'est
ça ce n'est pas propre aux influenceurs
quels sont les dérives possible et puis
on va venir évidemment à vos
propositions très concrètes on peut tout
monnayer sur les réseaux sociaux
Stéphane Végéta j'ai vu j'ai vu des
influenceurs monnayés le lot de leurs
bain ou les petites culottes qu'ils ont
porté tout le monde a vu ses vidéos j'en
suis sûr alors ça il y a pas de règle
pour empêcher ça j'ai pas vu ces story
là en particulier mais il y a pas de
règle spécifique qui s'appliquent aux
champs de l'influence effectivement de
l'influence commerciale moi pour
reprendre ce que disait madame je pense
qu'effectivement l'influence en ligne
l'influence marketing c'est un canal
légitime pour les annonceurs pour les
entreprises qui veulent donner une
certaine publicité à leurs produits à
leur service maintenant il y a la
manière de laquelle cette influence
s'exerce effectivement et le fait que
effectivement comme le dit mon mon
collègue Arthur de la porte la
régulation et la législation actuelle
est insuffisante notamment parce qu'elle
n'est pas adaptée à l'évolution d'un
monde qui qui avance à toute vitesse est
beaucoup plus vite que la loi je vous
rappelle ceci dit que Madame Nabila
avait été condamné
de publicité sur une campagne qui est
sponsoriser mais sur laquelle il n'y
avait effectivement pas de révélations
ou de transparence qu'en tout caractère
sponsorisé cette publication je voudrais
on va venir tout de suite est-ce que
vous proposer et on va bien comprendre
notamment les dérives est-ce qu'on
appelle le dropshipping moi j'ai
découvert ce mot personnellement il y a
aussi une question morale en tout cas
une question de société
Louise Aubery en fait est-ce que est-ce
que c'est ça qu'on veut montrer aux
jeunes générations des femmes qui vivent
à Dubaï souvent botoxées qui vendent des
produits de luxe en fait le truc est-ce
que c'est pas aussi une question
importante de se dire qu'il y a un
modèle qui est véhiculé avec ça bon en
fait si elle y va Dubaï ça relève même
plus vraiment de la de la législation
française du coup
il y a des acteurs qui se barrent à
Dubaï des des hommes d'affaires qui sont
des évadés fiscaux en Suisse enfin et je
trouve que la lumière qui est mise sur
les influenceurs oui elle est nécessaire
je trouve que là c'est de la charmante
parce que font tous les accords pour
dire il faut réguler le système de
l'influence pour qu'il y ait pas de
dérive une partie du marché d'influence
et en fait le débat tourne autour de
l'influence marketing mais dans
l'influence il y a pas que l'influence
marketing il y a les affaires publiques
le lobbying les stratégies d'influence
l'influencer avant tout le une
méthodologie le fait de mettre en place
une stratégie d'influence avec un
message qui est véhiculé c'est pas qu'un
messager l'influence c'est d'abord un
message et donc on ne peut pas résumer
l'influence ah sauf que là on parle du
marketing on parle de dérive on va y
venir mais sur la question morale parce
que
stratégie aussi de dessiner une société
et là c'est peut-être pas forcément le
législateur mais on est tous dans cette
société et on l'a construit tous
ensemble mais la moralité juste pardon
je les ai coupés
c'est vrai que nous notre enjeu c'est
pas de dire ce qui est moral ou pas
enfin qu'elle doivent être
comportementales mais par contre ce que
je constate et ce que je constate la
plupart des experts c'est que
l'influence aujourd'hui va véhiculer des
normes dites hyper sexualisées et en
fait où il faut forcément avoir voilà ce
que vous disiez un instant un corps
botoxé enfin ça peut donner en fait ce
type de modèle à des jeunes et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que quand on va
dans les classes moi j'étais ce matin
dans une classe collège autour de Caen
et c'est vrai que quand on discute avec
les jeunes on voit à quel point les
stéréotypes les modes de vie véhiculés
par les influenceurs peuvent générer des
souhaits des désirs après c'est pas
nouveau c'est juste que c'est une
évolution de la société
par exemple puisque vous dites que vous
êtes complètement adepte de la
communauté de Booba puisque vous êtes
pirates un jour pirate toujours c'est
marqué dans votre bio la communauté de
Booba qui est donc aujourd'hui suis
jamais trousse avec plus de 100.000
menaces de morts aujourd'hui vous en
faites partie de cette communauté
ouvertement
vous préférez en termes d'exemple
moralité adhérer aux paroles des
chansons de Booba qui sont complètement
sexistes et ignobles et qui encourage la
haine et la violence et le meurtre ou
vous préférez une personne comme moi qui
vous a jamais rien fait et je ne
véhicule jamais de haine et de violence
sur mes réseaux sociaux et peut-être je
suis beau toxique mais en tout cas moi
mes valeurs c'est pas la violence et
c'est pas la haine en fait je pense que
vous prenez probablement à l'envers je
pense que les gens sont venus me
chercher cette communauté venu me
chercher parce que j'avais effectivement
cette biographie de pirate de vision de
pirate en fait je me définis comme
pirate parce que j'ai été expulsé mon
parpaing en partie politique au cours
des dernières élections parce que je me
suis élevénement parti politique qui
présait préférer présenter Manuel Valls
à ma place je me suis présenté face à
lui j'ai gagné je me suis autodé fini
comme pirate c'est rester dans ma bio
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils sont
venus me chercher moi peut-être ou alors
peut-être qu'il cherchait chez quelqu'un
qui allait jusqu'au bout de ses combats
je ne sais pas toujours est-il que je
j'accepte moi j'accepte d'écouter les
personnes qui m'interpellent je suis
allé au fond du problème j'ai trouvé
effectivement l'évidence de certaines
arnaques de certaines victimes qui
existaient à partir de là moi je ne veux
surtout pas Piper je veux pas prendre
position il s'agit de faire le procès
tous les jours en recrutant les tweets
de Booba
et vous avez fait des commentaires si
vous voulez je peux vous les lire qui
sont assez si c'est le débat puisque si
j'ai la chance aujourd'hui d'être en
face de vous pour une fois et j'ai pas
eu l'occasion de vous parler mais vous
avez l'occasion de beaucoup
m'interpeller sur les réseaux sociaux
avec une meute si je voulais donnerai
après si vous voulez si vous voulez que
je lise maintenant mais je pense que
voilà mais je vous les donnerai après
non mais vous vous condamnez le
cyberharcèlement initié par Booba vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure en retwittant
c'est Monsieur Delaporte qui l'a dit
l'autre jour vous le condamnez ce
cyberracellement
donc
les tweets de Booba vous le faites
pourquoi c'est depuis ce super
un live aussi de Booba avec des
personnes dedans donc d'une personne qui
sort de prison d'ailleurs pour
escroquerie c'est marrant bon en disant
que j'étais protégé par l'Elysée vous
avez sous-entendu ça vous avez dit qu'on
vous l'avait dit et que vous avez
véhiculé ça mais cyberharceleur or je
voudrais savoir en quoi j'ai été protégé
par l'Elysée en rien parce que si
j'étais protégé par qui que ce soit j'en
serais pas je ne serai pas dans ma
situation pour répondre là-dessus et
puis ensuite on va revenir à notre à
notre sujet sur les dérives et surtout
sur la régulation alors je ne me
rappelle pas avoir retweeté en tout cas
je me rappelle pas avoir retweeté de
messages agressif de de cette personne
ni d'autres personnes lors du d'un
conversation que j'ai eu avec lui je lui
j'ai reconnu et je lui ai dit que je
l'avais utilisé tout comme cette
communauté mutilé moi en tant que
parlementaire pour essayer de faire
porter un message pour essayer de faire
changer les choses sur un sujet un
problème qui est réel à partir de là je
vous le répète madame madame Berda je
n'ai absolument rien contre vous et le
but du jeu c'est pas ici de faire le
procès de Booba versus
allez on va voir tout de suite avec
Clément pervaud ce que vous proposez
très concrètement quelle régulation et
puis quelle régulation peut-être contre
le dropshipping qu'est-ce que c'est et
est-ce qu'il faut l'empêcher la réponse
avec ce sujet
la proposition de loi vise d'abord à
interdire aux influenceurs la promotion
de certains produits sont concernés en
premier lieu les actes de chirurgie
dispositifs médicaux et produits
pharmaceutiques
[Musique]
dans ce domaine avec des promotions
d'articles proches du n'importe quoi
[Musique]
parce qu'elles ont les hormones en feu
achetez leur ça et en fait ça rajeunit
le vagin genre c'est trop bien il fait
vraiment plein plein de choses plus
grave encore l'influenceur Dylan a fait
en novembre la promotion de pilules
censée soigner le cancer c'est à dire
que si tu as des cellules confiées
cancérigeuses dans ton corps ce produit
là les tue et en fait c'est pas vendu en
France ni en Europe parce que c'est
interdit la proposition de loi interdit
également aux influenceurs de promouvoir
des placements financiers ainsi que des
actifs num comme les crypto monnaie
déplacements douteux sont régulièrement
promus par des influenceurs qui ne sont
pas franchement des experts en économie
[Musique]
complètement à investir dans la
crypto-monnaie et à vous éduquer le
texte encadre aussi la promotion des
paris sportifs contes de formation
professionnelle et jeux d'argent on va
prendre ça on va les poser concrètement
les promotions de ces produits devront
s'accompagner en permanence d'un bandeau
indiquant que l'usage est interdit aux
mineurs
plus globalement toute vidéo à caractère
promotionnel devra clairement être
indiqué comme tel cette obligation
existe déjà via une directive européenne
mais elle n'est pas toujours respectée
enfin la proposition de loi oblige
l'influenceur à informer l'acheteur du
fournisseur d'un produit l'objectif est
de lutter contre le dropshipping cette
pratique consiste à vendre à des abonnés
des produits que l'influenceur achète
tout simplement sur des plateformes de
vente en ligne en prenant au passage une
commission substantielle
ce texte est présenté comme une première
réponse pour réguler un nouveau business
qui s'apparente aujourd'hui au Far West
Arthur de Laporte le dropshipping je
fais la promotion d'un sèche-cheveux à
100 euros alors que vous le trouvez sur
Internet sur un site à 30 ça qu'est-ce
que vous allez faire contre ça c'est que
vous faites la promotion d'un
sèche-cheveux en le revendant mais vient
un site qui est en fait une espèce de
plateforme qui va faire de la commande
sur les Sèche-cheveux qui veulent par
exemple 5 euros qui sont sur type
Aliexpress un des plateformes de voilà
des sèche-cheveux pas forcément de bonne
qualité mais vous allez dire voilà sous
ses cheveux il est génial et avec mon
code promo vous avez en plus 20%, vous
au lieu de l'avoir à 70 euros vous
l'avez à 50 euros ça dure 24 heures et
vous mettez le code de la porte
sèche-cheveux et vous commentez
c'est pas illégal en soi mais en fait le
problème c'est que ça peut s'apparenter
à des pratiques commerciales trompeuses
et souvent en fait c'est des sites
vitrines qui sont créés
spécifiquement pour vendre ce produit et
les gens se rendent compte que soit le
produit il arrive pas parce que c'est
des sites soit c'est de la mauvaise
qualité et en fait en fait ils se
rendent compte qu'ils auraient pu avoir
le même à 4 euros donc en fait ils se
sentent souvent floués et ils ont eu
confiance dans les influenceurs qui font
de la pub pour ces produits là et
parfois moi j'ai vu l'exemple de pierre
et d'épinatoires qui en fait rendait la
peau rouge alors que l'influenceuse
avait dit regarder cette super pierre
elle est géniale et tout ça et donc en
fait et parfois c'est des produits qui
peuvent être dangereux mais
Bitcoin enfin ils des arnaques et des
dérives il y en a énormément de sujets
je faisais balayer un peu sur le
dropshipping qu'est-ce qui va permettre
de l'encadrer si je comprends bien ça
sera pas complètement interdit vous
pouvez pas interdire en soi
mais ce que en fait on veut faire en
sorte c'est de restaurer la confiance et
comme quand on dit restaurer la
confiance c'est mettre en place de la
transparence donc c'est dire qui est le
fournisseur et de cette assuré que les
sites par lesquels on passe
correspondent à des vraies entreprises
et pas à des choses qui sont créées de
manière éphémère spécifiquement pour
faire en fait un site vitrine
parce que je salue cette initiative je
pense qu'elle est nécessaire pour
restaurer sur la confiance mais là
encore une fois pour moi c'est pas
propre au monde de l'influence le
dropshipping ça existe depuis au final
l'émergence d'Internet et aujourd'hui il
y a beaucoup j'en connais des personnes
qui pour gagner de l'argent voilà que
des étudiants ou d'autres personnes qui
cherchent à arrondir leur fin de mois
vont créer des business qu'on appelle
automatisés en fait ils vont faire de la
pub ils vont faire des pubs sur Internet
justement pour du dropshipping et en
soit la mécanique exactement la même
donc en fait unique vous encadrez que
les influences
le messager comme disait Aurélie c'est
une bonne chose mais pour moi si jamais
il y a pas de condamnation sur quand
même ce rapport commercial qui est de
l'arnaque au final quand même frauduleux
je trouve ça dommage en fait Magali
berdavu vous en fait du dropshipping
alors nous on a fait et je me suis
jamais caché on en a fait le
dropshipping c'est un phénomène pour
nous qui a été un peu nouveau on va dire
vers 2018 on s'est fait envahir de de
sites qui sont arrivés personne
maîtrisait vraiment bien le drop et on
n'a pas trop compris quand on a vu les
les tous ces sites Instagram lanceurs
d'alerte parce qu'on a quand même des
très qualitatifs qui sont pas dans
l'agressivité mais qui sont dans la
prévention ça nous a aidé même nous à
apprendre en fait et à pouvoir balayer
beaucoup plus vite après ce genre de
site et à réguler en interne
le dropshipping nous aujourd'hui
dropshipping ça représente peut-être 5 %
de notre chiffre d'affaires qui est
vraiment minime quoi et c'est du
dropshipping correct parce que il y a
quand même du bon dropshipping il y en a
très peu malheureusement le dropshipping
est envahi par des gens malhonnêtes et
ça représente aujourd'hui 95 90% ou
c'est effectivement
pourriette
c'est des gens qui sont corrects qui ont
un site propre c'est le dropshipping il
y en a sur Amazon tous les jours il y en
a même à Téléshopping à TF1 tous les
jours aussi quand même des marges
gênants effectivement il y a des gens
qui ne livrent pas les colis parce qu'en
fait ils ont un fournisseur qui est en
Chine et ils font livrer le colis
directement de Chine au consommateurs et
souvent ils doivent payer donc le site
en caisse l'argent du consommateur mais
ne payent pas le fabricant donc le
fabricant ne rentre pas et c'est là où
on a une personne malhonnête et ce qu'on
doit taper c'est ces gens-là c'est ces
gens qui vont vite qui vont vite dans
l'arnaque en fait donc les influences
peuvent être victimes d'arnaques dans le
dropshipping vous allez interdire la
publicité sur certains produits
en fait à faire la liste de ce qu'on
souhaitait réguler de manière forte et
il y a par exemple les placements de
enfin les placements de produits pour
des crypto monnaie pour des NFT et ça
c'est vraiment des choses qu'on généré
des dérives énormes par exemple on voit
aujourd'hui avec l'affaire Blatta
notamment avec ce qu'on appelle le copy
trading donc des personnes qui ont en
fait des canal telegrammes sur lesquels
on va faire on va copier des placements
enfin des ordres de placement ou de
financiers en fait et derrière elles
vont perdre jusqu'à 1500 euros en
moyenne et même 50.000 euros pour
certains
toujours vanter les mérites de son de
son chirurgien ou c'est plus possible si
ça voté bien sûr ça pour le coup c'est
vrai que c'est des c'est des activités
qui sont assez fréquentes notamment chez
des influenceuses qui ont pu passer par
par votre agence où on fait de la pub
alors moi je pensais à leur Maëva game
je sais pas si c'est le travail avec
vous ou pas mais par exemple moi je
pense il a fait un certain nombre de
pubs et on en a vu tout à l'heure pour
voilà cette chirurgie enfin de la pub
qu'elle a fait il faut pas mélanger en
fait le problème dans ce milieu
qui a beaucoup de choses
tout le monde mélange tout et tout le
monde dit tout et n'importe quoi à son
interprétation live quand elle a parlé
de son de son de sa consultation chez
son gynéco c'est quelque chose de privé
peut-être que vous pouvez penser qu'elle
n'aurait pas dû le faire et je suis
d'accord avec vous d'ailleurs on en a
parlé s'en est excusé sur ses réseaux
sociaux ça c'est une évidence mais à
aucun moment c'était un partenariat
d'accord il y a pas eu de promotion donc
à chaque fois que je suis sur un
avantage en nature
et je vais vous dire quelque chose ça
c'est quelque chose de privé mais là
c'est la parole que vous engagez mais
aujourd'hui
en fait aujourd'hui
il y a des gens qui sont passés par mon
agence aujourd'hui des influenceuses qui
parlent de chirurgie esthétique il y en
a énormément agence ou pas c'est-à-dire
que mon agence ou pas on n'est pas
responsable de ça pourquoi parce que
faire la promotion chirurgie esthétique
c'est interdit c'est interdit déjà la
réglementation est déjà faite on n'a pas
le droit de le faire donc à aucun moment
vous trouverez un contrat avec un
chirurgien ou un hôpital et schon Evans
pour faire la promotion de choses ça
n'est jamais arrivé
on a encore beaucoup d'influenceurs qui
font de la pub pour des injections pour
des formations et finalement nous
aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut avec notre
toit c'est rappeler ce cadre faire de la
pédagogie et mettre des sanctions alors
Stéphane Végéta je voudrais qu'on parle
aussi du représentant légal parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de d'influenceurs qui qui
n'ont pas de représentants qui ont un
représentant à l'étranger ça ça va créer
un statut juridique de l'influenceur
c'est ça effectivement un des objectifs
de cette loi c'est de confirmer
certaines interdictions comme la
précisément collègue et ensuite
effectivement de mettre en place
l'encadrement qui s'assure que ces lois
vont être respectées d'abord par les
influenceurs eux-mêmes et leurs agents
et leur agence en s'assurant d'une
représentation légale en France de
l'agence ou de l'influenceur mais en
particulier de l'influenceur ce qui
permet ainsi de le ramener à portée de
la justice française même s'il réside à
l'étranger deuxièmement on va aussi
s'assurer en tout cas l'essayer que les
plateformes les réseaux sociaux se
responsabilisent pour les messages et
les contenus que diffusent des
influenceurs en particulier si euh soit
il y a des notifications suffisantes
soit les réseaux eux-mêmes sont capables
d'identifier dans certains contenus dans
certaines stories dans certains postes
des produits qui sont désormais définis
comme étant illégaux des produits ou
services et bien on veut que les
plateformes se responsabilisent et
prennent sur elle de débrancher ses
contenus ces histoires et ses promotions
ça aussi c'est important la
responsabilité des plateformes on parle
des influenceurs mais souvent c'est les
plateformes qui sont derrière Aurélie
Sioux un représentant légal pour créer
un statut juridique ça va dans bon sens
bien sûr mais
évidemment que tout ce qui est dit
aujourd'hui est très important on a on a
une toute petite partie immergée de
l'iceberg dont on parle aujourd'hui et
encore une fois les 99% dont on ne parle
pas c'est un qu'on résume l'influence à
la téléréalité on résume l'influence au
marketing d'influence c'est tellement
de vider donc c'est pour ça qu'on en
parle il y a un moment donné il faut le
dire parce que le fait que
surexpose toujours toujours les mêmes
éléments quand on entendait Stéphane
blackovski sur les 60% d'anomalies
dans les influenceurs vous avez des
créateurs de contenu des leaders
d'opinion des prescripteurs de tendance
vous avez des stars de la téléréalité de
quel 60% ne veut rien alors est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que ce qui est
proposé par les députés va permettre de
réduire le nombre d'arnaques mais des
escroquerie mais de toute façon ce
marché a besoin d'être assainies ça
c'est une évidence
ensuite il y a plusieurs conflits
d'intérêts il y a plusieurs
problématiques il faut poser le statut
de l'influenceur celui d'agent
d'influenceurs et la question que j'ai
est-ce que vous avez pensé aussi au
conflit d'intérêt entre le fait d'être
une agence de conseils en marketing
d'influence et en même temps agent
d'influenceur
sur le phénomène chat djibiti et puis
Bourbon Express elle vient mon Agava
nous dévoile la feuille de match de
lundi prochain sur les retraites mais
d'abord my better self c'est vous donc
Louise Aubery qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
exactement qu'est-ce que le body positif
et pourquoi ça n'a pas été si facile de
vous accepter au tout début comme vous
ayez déjà mais vous avez changé aussi on
en parle juste après l'invitation signé
ce soir parti Boeck
si on vous invite Louise Aubery c'est
que forze vous classe dans le top 10 des
influenceuses Françaises et qu'avec 800
000 followers vous auriez pu vous
lauriers mais que vous avez fait un
autre choix militer
que tu es féministe dans votre sphère
d'influence les femmes et dans votre
viseur les chaînes qu'on leur impose ou
qu'elles s'imposent elles-mêmes c'est
quoi là je retrouve juste un peu ma peau
personne le verra et tu penses que ça va
aider qui de faire ça Louise oberhy vous
aide donc influenceuse et entrepreneuse
un titre loin d'être usurpé car à 25 ans
on peut dire que vous avez beaucoup
entrepris en 2015 encore étudiante en
communication vous débutez sur Instagram
sous le pseudonyme my better self mon
meilleur mois trois ans plus tard vous
lancez vos premiers podcasts et vidéos
féministes baptisées inpower enfin en
2021 vous laissez de côté les
anglicismes et lancer votre marque de
lingerie inclusive pour tout l'an
dernier vous publiez un livre opération
de démolition de tous les préjugés que
vous voulez déconstruire on peut pas
déconstruire des années de ce qu'on
appelle de l'espace de la propagande du
prénom washing ou en fait pendant des
années les féminins ont matraqué comment
avoir une belle peau comment éliminer sa
cellulite comment perdre ses kilos voilà
en trop en 2019 vous lancez ainsi le
hashtag on veut du vrai un slogan qui
est devenu votre marque de fabrique vous
êtes ainsi l'une des fers de lance en
France du mouvement body positive une
philosophie venue des États-Unis et qui
consiste à montrer qu'il n'existe pas de
normes corporelles pour avoir une taille
maximum de bras pour avoir le droit de
poster sur les réseaux
bah non dans vos contenus vous parlez
aussi des inégalités économiques de la
précarité menstruelle ou des violences
faites aux femmes vous faites enfin la
pédagogie des théories féministes c'est
clairement une fessée
comme elle prend pas soin d'elle vous
avez peut-être déjà entendu ces phrases
de la bouche de certaines femmes c'est
ce qu'on appelle la misogynie
intériorisée c'est le fait d'avoir
tellement bien intégré les injonctions
de la féminité et du patriarcat que l'on
s'assure que les autres s'y plient aussi
se libérer des injonctions des
comparaisons Louise oberhy c'est selon
vous l'étape que doivent maintenant
franchir les femmes et la définition
d'un nouveau féminisme
un combat reste amené celui pour la
liberté liberté de porter ce que nous
voulons liberté de choisir la carrière
que nous souhaitons liberté de choisir
d'avoir des enfants ou de ne pas en
avoir au fond la liberté d'exister en
dehors du rôle que l'on nous a assigné
alors Louise obery une question pour
finir vous qui avez déconstruit tous ces
discours tous ces reflets déformés que
vous dit désormais votre miroir quand
vous vous y regardez
alors réponse c'est un peu le livre
d'ailleurs un que vous avez écrit miroir
miroir qu'est ce que vous pourrez
répondre qu'est-ce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui c'est une très bonne
question en fait c'est plutôt ce que je
ne vois plus et c'est du jugement c'est
à dire que j'arrive aujourd'hui à
regarder mon miroir sans me juger ce que
j'ai fait pendant des années et ce que
notamment les femmes sont encouragées
consciemment ou non à faire toute leur
vie parce que ça n'a pas toujours été
facile parce que vous êtes passé par une
phase de maigreur extrême assez obsédée
par votre apparence et l'admettre ça a
été longtemps comme ça des dictats que
esthétiques que vous voilà que vous
acceptiez en fait en fait je pense que
toutes les jeunes femmes sont soumises à
des injonctions sont préoccupées par
leur apparence physique et
ce qui est plutôt problématique c'est
que c'est socialement accepté et donc
c'est qu'on ne va pas voir les dangers
qu'il y a derrière et j'en ai fait les
frais en effet avec des troubles
commentaires une femme sur trois
victimes trop alimentaires et en fait
comme c'était un trouble invisible c'est
pas voilà on le voit pas forcément par
définition par essence et ce que je ce
que je dénonce au final dans mon livre
et vraiment la réflexion que j'ai eue
c'est que au final c'est une éducation
qu'on reçoit non pas forcément par nos
parents
aimer leur corps par exemple et bien
principalement les médias j'ai envie de
dire et et l'industrie
l'industrie cosmétique et les deux sont
d'ailleurs étroitement liés en fait
aujourd'hui j'ai je crois j'ai plus
exactement les budget en tête mais je
sais que c'est en centaines de milliards
d'euros que pèse voilà l'industrie de la
beauté destinée aux femmes en fait si on
s'aimait cette industrie s'effondrerait
donc en fait il y a un intérêt
fondamental il y a un réel intérêt pour
certains entreprises à ce que les femmes
continuent à avoir des complexes quelle
a été le déclic pour vous pour vous
dépendre de toutes ces injonctions c'est
progressif où il y a eu un événement il
y a pas de déclic honnêtement je pense
que pour 90% d'entre nous il y a c'est
pas du jour au lendemain on réalise
qu'en fait tout ça et est une mascara
des dons des victimes c'est c'est très
progressif c'est des prises de
conscience petit à petit et je pense
qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de en anglais
on dirait effectivement
fait semblant jusqu'à ce que tu lui
arrives et en fait c'est vrai que
moi-même j'ai commencé à parler
d'activation de soi sur les réseaux
avant même de réellement m'accepter et à
force d'en parler à force de voir le
bien que ça crée autour de moi ça m'a
poussé à continuer et en fait je ne sais
même pas quand exactement j'ai fini par
m'accepter mais voilà je dirais que ça
fait au moins un an deux que je n'ai
plus de complexe c'est que je m'accepte
comme je suis alors aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs vous ne planquez plus rien
non sur vos différents réseaux on le
voit bien les boutons les bourrelets
vous assumez tout on veut du vrai ça
c'est votre hashtag c'est le hashtag que
j'ai lancé en 2019 parce que les réseaux
sociaux notamment Instagram voilà c'est
une plateforme où on va beaucoup mettre
en scène et je pense que ça peut être
nocif non seulement pour la confiance en
soi des femmes mais c'est aussi quelque
chose dont je me rends compte plus
récemment pour la santé mentale en fait
des autres donc là je sors juste enfin
il y a le prise de la part en physique
évidemment vu que l'on se compare tout
le temps à d'autres et c'est notamment
retouchés mais il y a aussi cette espèce
de concours à la vie parfaite que je
trouve extrêmement nocif pour pour tout
un chacun et où moi j'essaye de montrer
mes réussites comme mes échecs mes bons
moments comme les moins bons moments
parce qu'en fait c'est tout simplement
normal et que pour moi le normal ne
devrait pas être
hiérarchisé par rapport à la mise en
scène je ne voudrais pas être évité
absolument on va justement regarder
cette vidéo qui a beaucoup tourné
c'était un gros succès vous avez osé ça
avec l'une de vos copines vous en pensez
quoi cette vitrine
elles sont très jolies moi je trouve que
c'est génial il faut que tout le monde
soit représenté bah écoutez c'est très
bien ça montre effectivement qu'on est
toutes différentes et qu'on n'est pas
que vous saviez pas que en 34 ou 36 et
qu'il faut habiller tout le monde
aimeriez justement qu'on voit plus un
par exemple moi un petit bidon
c'est leur mère qui les a nourris quand
elles étaient petites elles leur a trop
donné de sucre c'est drôle quand même
que ce soit la vieille dame qui vous
renvoie à faire un régime dans
l'ensemble c'est c'est bienveillant et
même bien venu qu'est-ce que vous tirez
de cette expérience là je je en fait
c'est plus un message à transmettre là
en l'occurrence tu es vraiment par
rapport à l'industrie de la mode parce
que voilà il y a j'ai aussi une marque
de sous-vêtements et c'est vrai que je
trouve ça assez dramatique de voir que
dans les sous-vêtements dans la lingerie
en France on représente que des femmes
qui font du 34 alors que il y en a
d'autres racontais même que vous avez eu
beaucoup de mal à trouver des mannequins
grande taille pour faire en fait là
cette vidéo parce qu'on est pas contexte
que certains ne comprendront collection
en fait c'est parce que on voulait une
mannequin grande taille pour notre
boutique éphémère et donc un mannequin
en plastique ça n'existe pas en fait ça
n'existe pas le plus grand c'est 42 et
ça coûte beaucoup plus cher qu'un
mannequin voilà de petites tailles donc
on s'est dit mais on va le faire
nous-mêmes et en fait je me doutais que
les gens allaient saluer l'initiative
donc en fait c'est justement pour dire
aux marques en fait regardez les gens
savent bien que les femmes font du 38 du
40 du 46 donc pourquoi est-ce que vous
acharnez à n'en représenter qu'une
petite partie la grosseophobie ça existe
encore aujourd'hui oui ça existe encore
et en fait c'est très insidieux souvent
on me sort l'excuse de la santé et ça
d'ailleurs c'est de tout âge que ce soit
la dame âgée qu'on a vu qui voilà hérite
d'un d'une époque dans laquelle elle a
vécu mais même des jeunes vont me dire
non mais après oui je suis d'accord il
faut s'accepter mais pas quand c'est
dangereux pour sa santé et il pense tout
de suite du coup au surpoids mais le
sous-poids l'anorexie c'est la maladie
mentale qui tue le plus de femmes dans
le monde et on en parle jamais on n'a
jamais fait de une de magazines sur les
troubles alimentaires sur les dangers de
l'anorexie dans votre livre est
particulièrement sur ces chapitres sur
le corps en particulier
et on comprend bien votre engagement
féministe vous dites que manger
finalement c'est un acte féministe vous
avez cette phrase l'acte de rébellion le
plus puissant que vous pouvez mener pour
dire à la société patriarcale d'aller se
faire c'est de manger votre
de gâteau je vous cite et de
kiffer sans culpabiliser c'est un acte
féministe de manger pour vous en fait
pour moi l'acte féministe c'est déjà de
reconnaître qu'on a de l'appétit parce
que j'en parle aussi dans le livre c'est
marrant mais les termes appétit
gourmandises ont forcément une cotation
sexuelle donc déjà vu que la femme n'est
pas censée avoir un appétit sexuel elle
va aussi l'associer à l'appétit
alimentaire donc elle va toujours être
dans l'espèce de restriction qu'on lui
impose mais c'est aussi justement pour
dire je m'en fiche de ce que le regard
de l'homme recherche je le fais pour moi
et c'est vrai que je trouve ça
extrêmement dommage enfin voilà
personnellement je le dis toujours sur
mes réseaux moi j'aime manger et encore
une fois c'est pas une invitation à
l'excès c'est juste que je suis une
bonne vivante comme vous avez des hommes
et merci pour ce message non mais voilà
il y a beaucoup de femmes qui et je
c'est mieux depuis quoi petite question
pour terminer vous êtes une féministe
qui pensait aussi aux hommes sans garder
sexe vous avez vu cette étude et au
conseil à l'égalité sur le sexisme le
backlash cette jeune génération qui au
fond il y aura un retour de bâton
réactionnaire contre le MiTo qui serait
censé une forme d'agression pour ces
jeunes vous le voyez vous en fait ça ne
m'étonne pas parce que les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui sont très
communautaires et donc permettent nous
permet de chercher l'information qu'on
veut avoir donc il y a énormément
d'hommes qui sont menacés par le
féminisme parce qu'ils ont décidé de
voir comme une menace parce que en fait
voilà vous m'avez présenté comme une
féministe qui ne déteste pas les hommes
c'est le cas de 99% des féministes et et
en fait aujourd'hui ce sont de menacés
par ça ils sont et masculins par notre
position et du coup ils vont suivre
démasculinistes des personnes qui ne
parlent que de ça et c'est pour moi
l'engrenage un peu malsain qui est en
train de se passer c'est une minorité
c'est une minorité mais évidemment les
réseaux nous incitent pas vraiment à des
personnes qui ne pensent pas comme nous
allez miroir miroir c'est aux éditions
Leduc 10 mois ce que je vaux vraiment
Louise au Berry vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis leur parti pris tout de suite
bonsoir les amis Marianne d'arrêt grosse
installez-vous et son mot de la semaine
mettre Bertrand Perrier bonsoir votre
regard sur cette société dont tout le
monde parle ce petit micro dans un
instant le H jppy bienvenue les amis on
commence évidemment par Bourbon Express
elles à mon Agava l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais
vous faire la feuille de match la
feuille d'un match qui va avoir lieu dès
la semaine prochaine dans l'hémicycle
celui évidemment sur la réforme des
retraites alors le gardien de but ce
sera le ministre au banc Olivier du soft
il est ministre du Travail alors il est
chargé de ne pas prendre de but
comprenez de vote contre la vie du
gouvernement il va falloir surveiller
les oppositions mais aussi le risque de
but contre son camp Olivier dussobe il
est passé du PS à en marche lors du
mercato en 2017 ces anciens coéquipiers
n'ont pas trop apprécié devrait lui
rappeler sur le terrain on va aussi voir
beaucoup pendant ce match les capitaines
d'équipe les présidents de groupe trois
présidents notamment Aurore berger pour
Renaissance Marine Le Pen pour le
rassemblement national Mathilde panot
pour les insoumis alors dans l'équipe de
la majorité on va retrouver des
personnages centraux Stéphanie Rist
c'est la rapporteur du texte Sylvain
Maillard et le responsable du texte pour
Renaissance Philippe Vigier pour le
modem ils vont être chargés de s'assurer
bien de la bonne mobilisation de leurs
équipes on peut s'attendre à des
causeries pendant les suspensions de
séances notamment pour demander à leurs
joueurs de muscler leur jeu alors
évidemment ça c'est pour la majorité les
défenseurs de la réforme va y avoir
beaucoup d'attaques exactement beaucoup
de monde beaucoup de monde les latéraux
à gauche prêt à tacler la majorité
François Ruffin pour les insoumis il
adore le foot il a réclamé il y a pas
longtemps un peu tendresse on verra s'il
en a sur le terrain de l'hémicycle
Arthur de Laporte vous le receviez il y
a un instant pour les socialistes
Sandrine Rousseau celle qui se
renvendique flemministes portera la
parole des écolos on va passer côté
droit les ailiers droits Stéphane Viry
chef de fil du groupe les républicains
il va devoir manier le grand écart pour
réconcilier un peu son groupe Aurélien
Pradier il est encore dans l'équipe mais
il pas tout à fait d'accord pour sur la
tactique il joue un peu perso en ce
moment les Alliés droits ils pourraient
revenir un peu dans l'axe et aider la
majorité à obtenir une majorité absolue
en suivra ça et puis encore plus à
droite il y a le RC rassemblement
national avec les joueurs lors la
Valette Thomas ménager dernier joueur je
vous l'ai dit on va pas oublier
comment l'oublier député depuis près de
30 ans je sais pas s'il connait bien les
règles du foot mais il connaît bien les
règles de l'assemblée et donc il sera
aussi sur le terrain on ajoute à tout
cela les arbitres Myriam ce sont les
présidentes séances ce qui peuvent
sortir les cartons jaunes et les cartons
rouges il y a le brun Pivet la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
devrait beaucoup présider et même quand
elle ne sera pas au perchoir elle
restera dans le coin au cas où côté
ambiance on a compris fair-play non
beaucoup beaucoup de tacles on aimerait
tous Myriam que ce soit un beau match
avec des frappes enroulés des petits
ponts et autres Panenka mais bah on a
bien peur que ce soit plutôt des tacles
du hors-jeu voire même de l'antigeu puis
je le rappelle le match c'est pas sur
Canal c'est pas green c'est sur LCP qui
va absolument l'intégralité du débat
retraite dès lundi matin sur LCP en
direct on sera tous au poste merci
beaucoup Elsa et merci à Pauline Lessard
pour toutes ces infos graphies on va
continuer sur les retraites parce que
c'est quand même lié votre mot de la
semaine Mariette c'est senior c'est
Seigneur voilà alors expliquez-nous
alors senior c'est un mot j'ai trouvé un
peu surprenant d'avoir dans le débat
politique parce que les syndical parce
que dans la vraie vie il est en train de
d'être en obsoliant ça avancer on
l'entend plus vraiment beaucoup ah bon
il est oui il est remplacé en fait par
deux mots alors un mot négatif bien sûr
vous pensez Myriam au boomer ok boomer
le nouveau seigneur c'est le boomer
c'est l'une le l'invariant du du vieux
ringard il y a pas de souci on voit ce
que c'est alors simplement le problème
c'est que il est face la valeur positive
qu'avait le mot senior et qui était
certes liée à la scène naissance à
Sénèque en latin etc mais aussi elle a
souveraineté le Seigneur vient de là le
cire il y avait quelque chose
d'intéressant alors
pourtant l'entreprise on est vieux quoi
à partir de quel âge alors le 45 ans en
entreprise oui alors après on sport on
est vieux à 20 ans le Seigneur dans
certains sports c'est 19 ans 20 ans
après on est vétérans bon tout est
relatif en entreprise on est vieux à 45
ans parce que on a moins de valeur sur
le marché du travail alors là il y a un
mot qui remplace seniors en entreprise
aujourd'hui qui est très à la mode c'est
le mentor on fait du manteauing il y a
quelque chose d'intéressant qui est en
train de se créer entre les générations
parce que les jeunes avec l'alternance
avec l'apprentissage envie de d'entrer
d'être un peu cadré les et les plus
âgées donne quelque chose mais je crois
que ce racisme anti 45 ans et plus de
l'entreprise ou d'une autre société qui
est très gêniste va cesser Myriam parce
que là on est devant un phénomène de
société très important dont on parle pas
tellement mais qui la révolution
démographique quand même qu'est-ce qui
se passe 50 ans c'est à certains égards
pour les gens qui ont de la chance la
moitié de la vie si on vit jusqu'à 100
donc il y a une espèce de tranche de vie
nouvelle 50 ans 4 ans avant la
vieillesse alors comment ça s'appelle ça
peut pas s'appeler senioriture comme
décrépitude voilà donc nous n'avons pas
encore de nom pour nourrir un mot il
faut trouver alors on m'a posé la
question j'ai pas réussi pour le moment
mais parce qu'on m'a dit bah s'il y a
les millenios alors qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire je me permets de rebondir
allez-y moi j'ai fait une table ronde il
y a deux jours sur le sujet de la
vieillesse et en fait donc j'ai reçu
entre autres perles à Saran Schreiber
qui va avoir 80 ans et qui réhabilite le
terme de vieillesse parce qu'en fait il
est pas négatif mais c'est un peu comme
le terme gros dont on parlait juste
avant il veut dire ce que ça veut dire
et elle elle est très heureuse de
vieillir donc on pourrait dire aller
vieux tout simplement alors les vieux
pour les vrais vieux mais entre 50 et
par là ceux qui désespérément voudrait
rester dans l'entreprise 50 60 en fait
voilà non mais ce qui est intéressant
avait nommer alors exactement moi je
pense qu'il ne faut pas les nommer qu'il
faut laisser justement le corps social
nous dire quelque chose là il nous dit
64 ans personne n'en veut parce que soit
les politiques pensent ou disent ou les
syndicalistes on est trop vieux pour
travailler mais je me demande si le
corps social nous dit pas exactement
l'inverse c'est-à-dire c'est là au
contraire d'une manière de faire
différente nouvelle c'est l'âge de la
liberté alors petit détail du marketing
mais les cartes seniors vous savez du
train ou s'appelle plus car c'est Niort
mais s'appelle carte liberté c'est quand
même assez amusant donc pour finir
est-ce que le gouvernement a pris
conscience de ça
le terme notamment la difficulté j'ai
pas l'impression parce que avoir fait
repris cet employabilité des seniors des
vieux mots je crois qu'il n'a pas assez
regardé il a trop regardé mais c'est un
défaut des politiques en général les
opinions et pas assez les pratiques et
quand on regarde les pratiques on voit
une chose intéressante qui me fait
penser que le nouveau mot un des
nouveaux mots pour dire ces nouveaux
seniors
du côté de l'activité nouvelle comment
les gens vont faire ils font déjà des
pratiques de loisirs bien sûr le sport
etc mais aussi des pratiques engagées
dans la cité et même de l'entreprise si
on regarde ce qui est en expansion
aujourd'hui le
l'auto-entrepreneur ou le
micro-entrepreneur comme il faut dire je
me demande si c'est pas ça le nouveau
nom du Seigneur parce qu'on a un pic à
moins de 30 ans et un autre pic
d'auto-entrepreneur à plus de 60 donc
j'ai l'impression que quelque chose à se
jouer du côté de l'activité
entrepreneuriale mais revisite
évidemment bon bah écoutez c'est des
pistes en tous les cas alors on va
enchaîner avec avec vous Bertrand pour
terminer bluffé ou pas par ce petit
robot dans tout le monde parle
je suis absolument sidéré il y a quelque
chose de complètement surnaturel
d'ailleurs ça a succès fou il y a plus
de 100 millions de nouveaux utilisateurs
au mois de janvier c'est le phénomène
dans tout le monde parle alors j'ai
essayé évidemment comme tout le monde
cette agent conversationnel
avec lequel on peut dialoguer alors
évidemment c'est de l'intelligence
artificielle mais on a vraiment
l'impression de dialoguer avec un humain
et on peut tout lui demander vous pouvez
lui demander le scénario d'une comédie
romantique un poème à la gloire de votre
maman
tout ce que vous voulez il le fait la
chronologie de l'Afghanistan depuis 2001
il vous le sort c'est absolument
incroyable et on a un texte encore hein
et c'est vraiment impressionnant alors
on sait que c'est de la compilation de
langage mais on a vraiment l'impression
d'un raisonnement et ce qui est fou
c'est qu'on peut vraiment engager un
dialogue j'ai essayé par exemple de lui
dire est-ce que tu peux me raconter un
mensonge et il m'a écrit les licornes
existent vraiment et je lui ai dit bah
oui c'est pas un mensonge en économie
les licornes existent et il m'a répondu
oui tout à fait en économie une licorne
désigne une entreprise valorisée à plus
de 1 milliard de dollars il s'agit donc
d'une vérité dans ce domaine donc j'ai
pu engager un vrai dialogue avec une
intelligence artificielle est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il pourrait s'engager
prendre parti
sur des questions de société alors
justement je lui ai demandé de prendre
parti sur le thème de l'émission
d'aujourd'hui à savoir la question de
l'encadrement du travail des
influenceurs et je vous lis la réponse
en quelques secondes ça prend moins de 5
secondes et il m'a dit certains
considèrent qu'il est nécessaire
d'encadrer ce secteur pour garantir la
transparence la responsabilité et la
protection des consommateurs
l'encadrement pourrait inclure des
règles sur la divulgation des relations
d'affaires et la publicité déguisée
ainsi que des normes éthiques pour les
pratiques de marketing en ligne
cependant d'autres considèrent
d'expression et la créativité des
influenceurs enfin c'est une vraie
dissertation assez bien balancée à ces
stéréotypées c'est vrai mais construite
et crit et argumenté évidemment il
fallait s'attendre aussi à ce qui est
quelques détournements évidemment alors
cette semaine une sénatrice a avoué
avoir fait écrire une question au
gouvernement par tchadjipiti un panel de
scientifiques s'est fait berner par des
fausses études rédigées par cadgipiti et
puis surtout bah c'est le Cauche des
enseignants en réalité parce que tout le
monde fait ses dissertations par 4G
pitty jacky est entré dans une
université américaine c'est-à-dire qu'il
a passé le test et il a réussi en spoile
interdit
assez brutalement alors qu'il aurait
peut-être été plus intéressants
d'éduquer les étudiants à l'employé mais
comme on ne sait pas le faire encore et
bien on préfère l'interdire sous peine
de sanctions et Stanford a mis au point
des systèmes de détection des copies
générées par checkgi il y a aussi des
enjeux très géopolitiques ah bah oui
évidemment c'est la Silicon Valley et on
a accusé
cette application c'est pas une
application d'ailleurs ce robot ce robot
d’être démocrate parce que il y a eu un
test on a dit voilà il veut bien faire
un poème à la gloire de Joe Biden mais
il veut pas faire un poème à la gloire
de Donald Trump et donc en conclusion
pitty est un modèle de langage
remarquable qui a déjà fait ses preuves
dans de nombreux domaines avec les
progrès continuent dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle il y a de
fortes chances que tchadjipiti continue
de jouer un rôle clé dans l'avenir de la
technologie ça c'est Chi vous avez
compris je lui ai demandé d'écrire ma
chronique merci non non je ne vous crois
pas vous avez trop de talents pour ça
oui mais pas le reste c'est sûr merci
beaucoup Bertrand merci Mariette et
merci à semaine prochaine
pour les retraites qui commencent à va
se passer j'aimerais bien j'aimerais
bien savoir la suite pas sûr qu'il est
la réponse merci beaucoup Louise d'être
venu sur le plateau DCP c'est le weekend
profitez bien très belle soirée bien sûr
et à lundi
[Musique]